[Applause]
Biden gives himself a pass for the cost
of food milk and gas instead blame the
grosser for your grief says the
vegetable in
Chief today's video of the day comes to
us from president poopy pants who
attacked grocery stores for continued
high prices hit at glattus a cost of
eggs milk chicken gas and so many other
essential items have come
down but for all we've done to bring
prices down there are still too many
corporations in America ripping people
off price gouging junk fees greed FL
shrink flation you see that article
about the Snickers
bars well it's going to stop America
we're tired of being played for
suckers and that's why we're going to
keep these
guys keep on them and get the prices
down so in Joe's mushy mind there's
greed inflation but no B inflation sorry
Gramps maybe those items would be
cheaper if stores did need to keep them
under lock and key fuel costs weren't
Skyhigh and the FED wasn't printing
money to give to other countries illegal
immigrants and student loan dead beats
otherwise known as Joe's core
constituencies the stores that aren't
already closing due to Crime are merely
responding to the inflation that jumped
under his administration which saps the
value of our paycheck it's worth less
and products are worth more so either
suddenly all the supermarket and food
producers got greedy at once or a scile
blowhard who never worked in the private
sector is wrong I'm betting on Joe Biden
harder than a Chinese
lobbyist
but but here again he attacks things
that unlike him keep America afloat
grocery chains natural gas a working
border law enforcement hell indoor
plumbing Joe should thank capitalism
every time he enters the store CU
without that system which works despite
everything the Dems do to undermine it
the American public would have turned on
him ages ago but as long as we have food
and booze and gas and Amazon and Netflix
Joe can lie about the country as easily
as he shakes hands with dead people but
he's right about one thing America is
tired of being played for suckers we can
only be distracted for so long with
bread and circuses especially when the
bread's double in price and the circus
clown is the guy in
charge cat is it me or does this guy
have no concept of how the economy Works
he always blames the outcomes for the
cause of the outcomes yeah it also just
kind of the whole thing felt very like
old man yells at Cloud yeah you know
he's like and the grocery stores and the
you know that the Snickers the thing the
Niger it's like and I told them you
better you're not and you're just like
okay Grandpa like and like you you got
them you're right like I don't think
anybody regardless of any of their
political views watches that and is like
you know I think he's on it
like I think he's got it I think when I
go to the store like he's going to take
people are just like okay I don't think
anyone's even thinking about it that
much anymore it's just like what like he
doesn't know how much anything costs he
doesn't know what he's saying I think
that even saying he doesn't know how the
economy works that's that's like a very
charitable to say that is anywhere even
close to that yeah Tyrus does this piss
you off or is it just
funny it's funny until I do the shopping
at my house yeah I he can't he's such
you know I try yes I tried hard to be
positive about the other side like I got
to talk about one thing yeah this dude
couldn't even get a story without about
snickers yeah without screwing it up and
think we don't know the difference
between lollipops and Snickers they took
us for suckers no the story is about
snickers it's a candy bar suckers is
something that you get you give to
people after they you let them smell
your
hair you know he's got a
know but the whole point of going after
president Trump was to expose him so we
had a for four years we had a
transparent White House we knew every
vote we knew who voted who didn't vote
we know who was responsible because they
were happy to tell us so Trump fixed the
Border by taking his pen and writing out
his really annoying evil signature that
they are all scared of and he added all
these laws to stop the border so now we
have a president who forgets we've been
watching for the last four years because
you made politics transparent by trying
to expose the evil red-headed monster so
we know how it works now MH and so when
he says I can't do anything whom are you
speaking to you showed us what Trump did
you could do the same thing so when he
says oh the it's the stores there's
never a follow-up question ever in this
ministration what stores who what stores
should we avoid specifically sir is it
Whole Foods is it fresh market like what
is the store that we should be focused
on doing this stuff because again to cat
point he has no no idea what he's
talking about and he the American people
we see it you can't you can no longer
you got when you got to kiss us now
before you bang us like we know now you
know what I'm saying we're not falling
for those other guys always said that I
did that yes it very different way of
saying it but but it's not believe it or
not I know it sounds naughty but it's
just me really aggressively saying give
me a hint yeah before you completely
screw me over and and he's not kissing
at all you know do you think with the
Snicker line he was like he saw one of
the Snickers from Halloween the little
funsize things CU look what's
happening they used to be this big and
now they
[Applause]
clown they're they're not trying to hide
his dementia anymore they're telling him
just go with it you know
um uh he called American suckers for
paying retail for groceries what what
are we supposed to do shoplift
yeah or haggle you know it says this
spam is four bucks I'll give you
two
uh that was the greatest insult of my
lifetime that a president has paid me
that I'm a sucker for wanting to eat and
not being willing to shoplift my food
yeah you know it's funny
you're
right we've said this on the show we
feel like suckers when we watch people
people running out of Costco with 900
bucks or whatever worth of stuff and
we're going like why are we doing that
we are the suckers he just told us we're
the suckers for putting up with this
crap I mean we really are
uh not only is cat right does he sound
like he's ranting in a you know dog park
or something
um but but but but he's turning on
everybody who's productive on behalf of
everybody who isn't and I'm tired of his
insults I I I I could win the insult
contest 10 times over with him but he
gets to be on TV and I don't get to talk
back except when I come here exactly you
know it's true like Trump insulted the
power they didn't he never insulted the
people and that's all Joe does is insult
the people but it's from a position of
ignorance he completely has no idea how
a supermarket Works do you you think
these supermarkets want the prices to be
high absolutely not they don't make
money off of the price being high they
make money off of prices being low and
selling more Goods because they are a
volume business so if you have more
money in your pocket and you can buy
more Goods that grocery store makes more
money so if he doesn't understand that
simple transaction how can he run the
economy oh wait he can't yeah it's true
it's like I why do they have sales right
it's like they low prices are what gets
people in what an idiot all
right I'm almost done with them coming
up all Joe's obsessed with the dumbest
members of hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else